alors le résoudre ce problème par là
pour trouver la solution d'un stade
louis-ii sérieusement c'était un beau
match
laurent robert n'avait plus marqué
depuis le 2 décembre un quart d'heure de
la fin voilà
mais il ya eu josé maría dernière minute
oui mais je crois que dans l'ensemble on
peut être satisfait moi personnellement
j'ai été satisfait de la prestation des
jours je crois qu'a longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu jouer l'équipe d'eva
sport ou en y mettant de la qualité en
émettant du un état d'esprit en
retrouvant certaines choses qu'on avait
perdu certaines étant comme tu l'as si
bien dit dans tes fiches il ya longtemps
et bon bah tu sais il faut mettre un
certain temps pour retrouver une équipe
l'ont essayé de diverses et j'y suis
pour je suis là pour ça alors l'avenir
c'est le quart de finale aller il faut
faire un sans faute là parce que il ya
la corogne le 7 mars et galatasaray le
13 mars il faut gagner les deux matches
c'est possible ça c'est jouable
s'ils jouent à je crois que c'est
possible voilà il ya un suspense avait
nommément et c'est toujours bon d'y
croire on va regarder
actuellement il ya un adversaire qui est
la corogne qui est a priori difficile
ouais mais en football on peut toujours
penser renversé ouais on peut y arriver
parce qu'il reste que salah au niveau
hexagonal éliminé de la coupe de france
son 16e de finale de la ligue coupe de
la ligue
voilà un championnat 12e sur 18
appareils un relégué en d2
non je crois pas je crois que l'équipe a
suffisamment de qualité et de fierté
d'orgueil pour pour s'en sortir bien
luis fernandes la france veut en savoir
plus
interview vérité
on est choqué laurent baffie monnaie
serait déchiré la gueule
j'aime bien je le préviens alors non pas
du tout luis en 96 vous déclariez à
l'équipe magazine
j'attendrai le temps qu'il faudra mais
je suis convaincu que je reviendrai au
psg aujourd'hui vous regretter d'être
venu belles choses est pas quelque part
quelque chose que je l'avais pensé je
l'avais imaginé c'est pas si rapidement
que ça puisque après avoir passé quatre
années comme celle que j'ai passé en
espagne ont vécu dans un championnat
comme le championnat espagnol
je m'étais donné une année sabbatique un
peu et dans le dans ce monde qui est un
peu un monde et le milieu du football
qui a énormément bougé
il ya beaucoup de choses qui qui bouge
bon maintenant il n'est pas alors non je
ne regrette pas du tout c est un club
que j'aime et que bien il fait partie de
moi alors est ce que vous vivez la plus
mauvaise période de votre carrière
d'entraîneur non non non parce qu'il ya
il ya des moments difficiles c'est
éventuellement à la télé ça arrive aussi
un oui mais dans les 8 années
d'entraîneur depuis le début
parfois j'ai eu des moments difficiles
et que bon bah les gens sont pas censés
savoir ne pas reconnaître à moi de bien
savoir les passer ces moments là et
pourquoi le psg gagne plus en fait pour
qu'ils ne gagnent plus le pg je crois
qu'il ya eu quand on voit un peu la
situation du club et on voit un peu ces
dix dernières années à chaque année a
toujours un une période un peu délicate
un peu difficile et le club a toujours
ce mauvais passage et qu'on arrive pas
relativement à essayer de trouver la
solution à moi et je pense que
personnellement j'ai quelques idées
là-dessus bien
alors quand lors de la défaite j'ai 10
février à auxerre vous avez déclaré que
c'est peut-être de la malchance vais
parler de corbeaux et de chats noirs et
c'est vrai que le 20 février contre le
milan ac
égalisation à la dernière minute il ya
un mauvais sort contre le psg je ne
dirais pas qu'il est mauvais sort il ya
un an on peut dire que dans le sport il
ya des périodes comme ça qu'il faut
savoir analyser qu'il faut savoir
essayer de comprendre même si parfois on
essaie de se dire bon on a trouvé une
solution mais que le football le sport
en général il n'y a rien d'acquis mais
que ça aussi ça fait partie dans le
football de ces moments difficiles
une équipe travaille à trouver sort
parce que laurent ruquier a essayé de
désenvoûter le psg version démission
mardi dernier il a presque réussi il a
presque réussi à presque réussi le
journal nu alors oui moi il a presque
réussi parce qu'on a fait un bon match
face à milan ouais et on dirait je
dirais plutôt que c'est sur ces matches
là qu'on travaille un peu sur pour
l'avenir ouais alors pour en revenir à
la ligue des champions compte tenu des
performances actuelles de l'équipe
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que ses
deux victoires en deux matches sont
possibles
oui oui oui tout est possible je dirais
que quand on voit l'équipe réalisé un
bon match face au milan ac en y mettant
de la qualité on y mettra un état
d'esprit on dit que la coupe d'europe ça
c'est un parfum un peu spécial ça les
joueurs aiment cette compétition là et
la joue parce qu'ils savent que c'est un
peu la vitrine c'est à dire que ces
joueurs là du psg
ils se battent que concéder des trucs un
peu valorisant quand c'est la ligue des
champions ça ces exceptions qu'avec des
champions ça transcende ça ça motive ça
ce que pense et si regardez dans
dans le monde entier on a tous sont
réglés avec des champions c'est la coupe
d'europe c'est le c'est un des objectifs
bon c'était peut-être pas celui du pg
cette année c'était d'arriver en quarts
de finale alors il faut éventuellement
il forçait à la corogne contre la
corogne avec le psg sans ça je sais que
vous dites on peut y arriver est arrivé
ouais non c'est parce que j'ai gagné là
moi c'est que je crois que l'effectif où
l'équipe en réalisant ce qu'elle a
réalisé cette année tant elle est
capable de gagner à la corogne
est-ce qu'ils sont pas trop payés trop
gâté les joueurs du psg aujourd'hui je
ne dirais pas je le dirai pas comme ça
je dirais que le football en depuis la
loi bosman depuis le sait ces
changements c'est d'un étang et à un
bouleversement des données et il
faudrait s'y pencher mais bon on ce sont
des artistes les garçons qui essaye de
faire le mieux possible que si on dit
qu'on est trop payé dans le football je
dirais que dans d'autres professions si
on est trop payé réellement inexpressif
pourquoi vous changer si souvent luis la
formation de l'équipe ce programme est
quand même énormément de compétition
contient un effectif surtout quand en un
comme celui que tu as eu la main tu as
20 à 25 joueurs qui sont également où il
ya de la qualité
tu es obligé de faire un tour 9 heures
l'entraîneur nantais reynald hendrix le
disais il ya pas très longtemps
pourtant il est deuxième du championnat
avec des options de gagner la coupe de
france la coupe de la ligue il en coupe
d'europe et en championnat avant il est
dans le vrai et je pense aussi comme lui
que quand tu as beaucoup de compétition
il faut aussi penser à faire tourner un
peu trop figure alors quand tu gagnes
personnes le nom pas et quand tu perds
mon mascara
alors quand on parle maintenant on va
dire aussi sur la tactique
tu change souvent de système tactique tu
joues avec 3 avec 4 avec 5 les joueurs
sont un peu perdus mais ils sont censés
être professionnel aussi le joueur doit
s'adapter à toutes les situations
est ce que mon entraîneur on doit
s'adapter ci contre le milan ac je
m'aperçois que je joue dans un système
et que ça se passe mal à moins
d'interpréter le jeu à moins de changer
et le jour est capable d'analyser qu'il
faut changer le joueur a su le faire
face à milan c'est en se faisant
construire on rentre un peu dans c dans
ses systèmes et les médias veulent
savoir quand des voix
la télé est sur le banc de touche c'est
un vrai spectacle arrêtez de le voir et
parce que en tout cas il m'a guidé son
match il a l'air sincère dont il a
l'image qu'on a vu tout à l'heure là
c'était une magnifique l'aller j'ai vu
le visage détruit par le mas et je suis
détruit
ça fait mal pour les jours parce qu'il
ne mérite pas un mérite pas de prendre
un but comme ça la minute quand on voit
ce qu'ils ont réalisé durant 90
autant je peux être déçu après match de
guingamp de la deuxième mi temps
lorsqu'on perd 3 à la maison je peux
être déçu parce que parce que ces
comportements peut-être il ya eu un
relâchement mais après une défaite après
un match nul comme suit 2 face au milan
quand on prend un but crucial et louis
smith fuit devant la place de la poule
psg un match nul en ce moment ses bons
rapports parce que j'ai vu quelque part
tous les soirs quand il commence il y
encore un jour sans que le pg et gagner
avec ses du réseau alors est-ce que
pourquoi vous nous obligez pas anelka a
parlé à la presse les médias se sont
acharnés un peu sonné quand la jouerai
mon jeu
dire que nicolas c'est quand on le
connaît bien quand on le voit vivre au
sein d'un groupe
c'est quelqu'un de très il est charmant
il est il est sympa il est en plus de
sacrifier le soignant qui pourrissent à
kiwi alors justement
contrairement à ça quand ils vendent
espagne qui fait un contrat de sept ans
il n'a pas à y revenir un an après au
pressage en main parce qu'il peut rester
ces temps là bas et éventuellement il
peut se mettre vraiment tranquillement
mais jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
ouais pour te dire ce qu'il a laissé la
voir pour revenir jouer en footballeur
tous les artistes non je pense moi - oui
je pense à une carrière beaucoup plus
longue
dans un autre extrait des carrières qui
sont claires très bientôt sur une
dizaine d'années
ouais mais on n'en gagne que pendant
cinq six ans si dans les cinq premières
années deviennent presque voir l'année
prochaine si vous n'êtes pas bon ça ne
suffisait pas en coupe d'europe et
garder anelka quand même un bon quand il
fait partie de ces garçons sur lesquels
on compte mais je crois que c'est bien
il est moins polluer nancy paris c'est
quand même un grand club
récemment c'est un club qui fait rêver
qui en europe
quand on parle du passionnément en
espagne cette anguille qui aspire à être
hyper considéré et en espagne une bonne
cote le psg annoncé pour le manger c'est
très connu
oui je sais pas mais j'accepte ya pas de
problème bien est ce que laurent perpère
et compétents comme une crise très
compétent apparemment ce que l'on peut
discuter partager les meilleurs que
denisot comme 5 0 comme ça je dirais
qu'il est différent il a sa méthode
perpère et quand même quelqu'un qui
laisse travailler son entraîneur et qui
le laisse faire ce qu'il a à faire et
que me laisse travailler tranquillement
alors les supporters ils sont pas
contents 1 je les ai rencontrés a pas
très longtemps sans pas contents ils ont
rencontré les gens et on peut en drôles
ils ont fait une banderole avec ww point
équipe de merde point fr et quand même
mais bon ça c'est un peu le
et puis sur la halle tard sur la route
du camp des loges il ya quelques temps
on les a un peu capable pendant les
matches valence et du bien-être sur la
voiture de perpère aussi causer mais
leca qui prend aussi la sueur de m le
présent populaire et vosges et les
rencontrer j'ai vu à la rencontre des
supporters ce qu'il est réellement
c'est souvent rien là qui ce qui se
cache et crèches et qu'est ce qu'il leur
a dit est ensemble on s'est retrouvé
avec 300 400 supporters on leur
expliquait on leur a donné des raisons
de bon vin que la situation n'était pas
au mieux ouais c'est normal qu'ils
soient déçus mais il faut qu'on reste
solidaire pour qu on reste unis la
bourse entre intérêts de suicide de 13%
des supporters qu'il faudrait quand même
verrouillé l'histoire maintenant on
verra bien